let's get into the Friday mailbag info
at davidpackman.com must be spelled
correctly not the info well actually it
all has to be spelled correctly but the
info part is the easy part it's my last
name that often trips people up you can
send questions comments criticisms
praise try to keep the trolling to a
minimum even though there's always a
little bit and maybe that's where we
will start today first message is your
y-o-u-r an F wit Pac-Man and they they
say the full thing with the F you must
support the Looney left pedos
and petos also with an apostrophe it's
all weird and it does contain the
required your you are confusion almost
exclusively uh uh almost unanimously in
the hate mail that I receive and also
not a particularly substantive criticism
and this entire thing with left-wing
pedophilia not only is it like a strange
obsession for many on the right
it really actually seems like it's the
right that has a problem with this issue
but let's not make it political let's
just leave it at that another message
not pleased with my commentary I watched
your insulting Herschel Walker video and
I gotta say as someone who had worked
with the developmentally disabled and
mentally ill you should be ashamed I
reported your garbage commentary to
Facebook you do realize people with
brain injuries can work
also wondering if Walker was a Democrat
would you have still said everything you
did yes guys
first of all this person seems to be
saying Herschel Walker is
developmentally disabled or mentally ill
or has a brain injury which the right
denies and now this person is saying not
only is it true you're bad for bringing
it up David I was not making fun of
anything I was not saying anything other
than this guy cannot speak he cannot
form a coherent sentence he should
obviously not be a valid candidate to be
one of 100 senators in the United States
whatever issues he's dealing with if
it's mental illness he should get
treatment if it's a brain injury he
should get treatment if it's a
developmental disability
full dignity and respect to all of it
and his inability to express himself
about even one issue that is important
to him should make it so that no voter
would say this is the guy that needs to
be a senator that's the point
and that's as far as it goes next email
is from Sarah now I'm gonna have to keep
doing this in order for people to
understand what's going on Sarah wrote
to me and said possible scam in your
name David
I subscribe to the David Pacman show on
YouTube recently David included a photo
of himself with his child to which I
commented congratulations upon seeing
notifications later I noticed there was
a response supposedly by David but which
immediately raised my hackles as a scam
I've copied the text to include with
this email and it's someone that looks
like me telling Sarah to DM them on
WhatsApp I want to make we are we are
playing whack-a-mole with these spammers
okay I am not trying to contact any of
you by WhatsApp or text message I love
all the fans all the viewers the
audience love all of you
I'm not trying to text you I'm not
trying to Whatsapp you I am too busy and
there are dozens of accounts using my
face if you can imagine a face like this
it's being used to scam people into like
eventually it will be about they'll
invest your money for you or they need
you know whatever it's some Financial
scam so if you see any account that
claims to be me trying to get you to
contact them or saying I want to text
you or whatever report it for
impersonation it is not me I can talk to
you if you call in
okay when we take live calls I am not
trying to text anybody love everybody
with peace and love I'm not trying to
Whatsapp you I'm not trying to text you
all right Sarah Matthias wrote in about
monkey pox and one of the things I
really don't like
is when people criticize me for things I
didn't say
I say plenty on the show worthy of
criticism criticize me for that not for
things I didn't say Matthias says sir
yesterday you mentioned it was
homophobic to bring up the fact that the
vast majority of monkey pox cases are
men who have sex with men
isn't it a disservice to be dishonest
with the gay community
I did not say that it is homophobic to
bring up the fact that the majority of
cases early on were men who have sex
with men
what I said was that it was homophobic
not to care about monkey pox because you
believe it is only affecting gay men
which is what Marjorie Taylor green was
saying
am I this poor a communicator that
people thought I was being homophobic or
or sorry that I was saying it was
homophobic merely to point out a
statistic no that is not what I said
what I said was there are people on the
right laughing this off like they
laughed off aids for a while
by saying I don't care about this it's
only affecting gay men and it is not
only affecting gay men I just actually
got a message from a woman
um who has monkey pox and I guess now
she's over it actually she caught it two
months ago
um come on guys come on that criticized
me for the things that I'm saying
CMA wrote to me about live golf
and says I have little confidence you'll
pay attention to this but I'm giving it
a shot
I saw your comments about the live golf
tournament please it is not live golf
it's 54 golf I expected much more of you
a cultured celebrity Liv is a Roman
number 54 Liv placing it in the name of
the tournament refers to the number of
hits a player would need to make if all
the holes were par or something like
that please 54 golf not live golf
I have not heard a single news report
Sports channel golfer or athlete call it
54 golf
okay
everyone's calling it live golf I get it
I understand Roman numerals but I've not
heard it called 54 golf even once so
it seems it would be weird
if all of a sudden I start calling it 54
golf I don't think anyone would have any
idea what I'm talking about all right
CMA
so I want to be understood
that's the priority Chris wrote in about
electric cars
a topic near and dear to my heart
Chris says David thank you for
addressing the issue of right wing
disgust against electric cars and
similarly any type of Green Tech
I've been driving an electric car for
almost five years I've experienced
everything that you have and I agree
with everything that you said in this
segment if there was ever a litmus test
of right-wing intelligence or lack
thereof the reaction to electric cars is
it yet they really don't understand
anything another one that I'm hearing is
that they're saying you know electric
cars you need metal you need tires you
need right but you need those things
with internal combustion engines as well
but at least you're not burning fossil
fuels when you drive around I get it
there's still a carbon footprint to an
electric car nobody's denying that but
they seem increasingly desperate
ignorant and unhinged in the criticism
of electric vehicles and by the way no
one's forcing you to go and get an
electric vehicle if you're happy with
paying for gas and you know the noise of
internal combustion engines and all the
moving parts that can break and uh stick
with it no nobody's forcing you to get
an electric vehicle it's just as the
technology matures and the charging
Network expands and the vehicles improve
and get cheaper and cheaper
those internal combustion engines are
looking pretty Antiquated I think that's
the main point Jason wrote in about fuel
prices and as another interesting take
on the electric vehicle discussion Jason
says I don't own an electric vehicle
currently and don't benefit from high
prices so high prices are a net negative
for me financially however based on the
need to reduce our dependence on fossil
fuels I'm actually to the point where I
don't want fuel prices to come down
while I don't want to see the oil
corporation's benefit I also think big
picture we need to reduce demand and use
this in some way tactically I don't know
what it looks like do you think there's
any chance the masses will understand
how the need to prioritize the existence
of our species or planet has to come
before any economic interest yeah I've
mentioned this before in a different
context which is super high gas prices
aren't necessarily the best for oil
companies and gas stations long term
because they reduce demand
and uh this is sort of what the point
Jason is making if gas prices are
cartoonishly high it makes electric
vehicles comparatively less expensive
because it increases the cost of
ownership of a of a a gas-powered
vehicle and Jason is absolutely correct
absolutely correct
Brian wrote in about 3D printed guns you
might remember that a homemade gun was
used in the assassination of the former
Japanese prime minister Shinzo Abe and
Brian says if we can digitally keep
photocopiers from duplicating currency
why couldn't we use the same concept to
keep 3D printers from producing gun
parts make it recognize a part in any
plane and have updates just think and
keep up the great work yeah this this is
an important thing
um
we have seen a lot of people on the
right
when presented with the obvious need for
gun safety regulations they go Hey
listen even if you get rid of guns the
guy in Japan printed his gun at home or
made his gun at home so getting rid of
guns won't solve anything well it would
in the sense that most people aren't
going to be able to make a gun at home
and the ones that are able to do it
aren't necessarily going to do it
because it's more work and people are
fundamentally lazy so obviously will
some people figure out a way to print
guns at home if you ban the ability to
buy a certain gun on the open market
yeah
but most of them are not and then you
get to the next question which is just
because you could print a gun at home
even though most people won't you can
also regulate 3D printers in some way
and I know that you could make the case
well you can slice and dice the parts
thinner and thinner to where they
wouldn't be recognized as gun parts okay
I get it but the point is you also can
make it more difficult to print a 3D gun
at home for those that have a 3D printer
it's weird how they act like we have no
agency or ability to control technology
whatsoever everybody will just print
guns at home oh will they well most
people don't have printers and even if
they did you can also uh limit some of
the parts that can be printed they just
throw in the towel like we have no more
power the email is absolutely correct
send me your thoughts questions comments
concerns demands for an apology
hopefully a legitimate demand to info
davidpackman.com and the party doesn't
have to stop now we do have the bonus
show every single weekday oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 get the bonus show
folks if Alex Jones doesn't like it it
should at least pique your interest a
little bit see you then